all right welcome to this Friday special
edition of Hannity Biden's leadership
failures now we begin with a very simple
question and every American needs to ask
this question are you better off now
than you were four years ago according
to virtually every poll every indicator
the answer is a resounding no and
Americans now clearly see who is at
fault from day one Joe Biden has failed
to lead on every major issue of our day
ask yourself can you name one major
accomplishment now some blame by his age
and obvious cognitive decline others
believe the Joe's not that bright no I
tend to believe both and he's in over
his head but at the very core of Biden's
leadership failures is basically his
character or frankly his lack thereof
now for decades Biden's moral cowardice
poor judgment went under the radar
during you know easy senate elections in
deep blue Delaware and during an
eight-year stint writing Barack Obama's
co-tells as vice president and in 2020
during a desperate bid to unseat Donald
Trump oh the media mob big Tech
countless government bureaucrats FBI
while meeting with big Tech weekly they
all work together to sweep Joe Biden's
alleged corruption under the rug but as
a failing president there is nowhere
left for Biden now to hide look at this
cover today's New York Post 61 percent
believe that your President Joe Biden
was involved in Hunter Biden's business
something he swore that not once did he
ever talk to his son brother or anybody
for that matter about now the post is
referencing a CNN poll and the numbers
get even worse among Independents 64
percent of this very important voting
block believe that Joe Biden was
involved in his son's Shady business
deals you know Millions tens of millions
of dollars China Russia Kazakhstan
Ukraine Romania Mexico ago other
countries and out of everyone polled who
believes Biden was involved with
Hunter's businesses yeah 69 percent
think that Joe Biden broke the law now
of course everyone is innocent until
proven guilty but there is real evidence
of bribery corruption tax fraud Pharaoh
violations and money laundering that's
why I call it the Joe Biden money
laundering and bribery Scandal
allegations you have pictures you have
text you have videos you have emails
bank statements eyewitness testimony the
FBI 1023 form government whistleblowers
and so much more and of course when
you're a top Democrat well none of that
seems to matter especially when it's
your executive branch that has your
Department of Justice and your FBI and
right now we have a politicized and
weaponized doj they went after former
Virginia governor we had him on this
program Bob McDonald member he took out
a loan from a close personal friend paid
it back they wanted to lock him up for
years but the Supreme Court unanimously
how rare is that they overturned and
vacated the guilty verdict when it comes
to Biden well they can rake in tens of
millions of dollars from foreign
countries many adversarial countries in
exchange for Access and favor favors and
then failed to pay taxes on it but don't
worry uh the investigator will let the
statute of limitations run out and the
doj simply doesn't even seem to care but
you the American people can see the
obvious truth Joe Biden is corrupt he's
dishonest and it's not just the Biden
family business Biden lies and
obfuscates non-stop constantly look at
the border oh the border is secure we've
been told over and over again he's done
more to secure the Border than anyone
else before him there's no crisis at the
border even though Democrats like Eric
Adams in New York City they're now
freaking out as our other towns and
cities you have America's Sanctuary
cities and states they can't handle
Joe's influx of illegal immigrants in
three years the number may be as high as
8 million illegal immigrants aided and
abetted by your president allowed into
this country now New York City just
approved a massive housing complex for
illegal immigrants in an abandoned
building in Chicago O'Hare the city's
international airport they're now being
used as an illegal immigrant shelter
this is completely out of hand we are
certainly better than this but
apparently now Joe is attempting to
quell any and all descent from the left
not by securing the Border but trying to
force illegal immigrants we must now
remain in Texas not Mexico Texas okay
one big problem illegal immigrants from
all over the world are now pouring in
from the northern border Canada in
places because they're coming from
places we never dreamed of this is what
failed lead leadership looks like and
under Joe Biden it will not get better
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else